well this afternoon I sat down with all
the police Chiefs to make it clear that
they have my full support in acting
decisively to clamp down on illegal
protests it is completely unacceptable
that ordinary members of the public are
having their lives disrupted by a
selfish minority my view is that those
who break the law should feel the full
force of it and that's what I'm
determined to deliver
you bring in new legislation either
increased powers for police officers
what are you doing to help them we are
currently giving the police new powers
so that they can clap down on these
illegal protests they will have my full
support in acting decisively and rapidly
to end the misery and the disruption
that's being caused to ordinary families
up and down the country who are trying
to go about their day-to-day lives and
I've said to the police but whatever
they need from government they will have
in terms of new powers but already
giving them some and I want to back them
to use them institutional racism has
been found within the London fire
brigade in some police forces now the
victim of the royal race rail says
Buckingham Palace is also
institutionally racist is she right well
it wouldn't be right for me to comment
on matters to do with the Royal Palace
although as we've all seen they've
acknowledged what's happened and made an
apology for it
how did you feel when you heard this
story are those sentiments that you have
experienced in your life at all so I
mean I I've as I've talked about in the
past I have experienced racism in my
life but what I'm pleased to say is some
of the things that I experienced when I
was a kid and a young person I don't
think would happen today because our
country's made incredible progress in
tackling racism but the job is never
done and that's why whenever we see it
we must confront it and it's right that
we continually learn the lessons and
move to a better future union leaders
are threatening coordinated strike
action across the NHS this winter do you
think it's dangerous do you think that's
irresponsible and can the NHS cope well
I think it's deeply regrettable that
we're seeing strikes across some parts
of the public sector now I I know things
are difficult for people right now
economically but when it comes to pay
settlements they have to be fair both
for workers but also for taxpayers
that's why we have an independent body
that makes recommendations to the
government about what Fair pay
settlements are and actually the
government has accepted all of those
independent recommendations and I would
encourage unions and employers to keep
talking so that we can find a way
through this but are you concerned what
that could mean if paramedics and NHS
staff are striking I said is is very
regrettable that we are seeing the
threat of strike action the NHS have
very robust contingency plans in place
to ensure that we continue to give care
to the people we do but I would urge
unions to sit down and talk with
employers to find a way through this
we've accepted all the recommendations
of the independent bodies on pay who
balance the competing needs and make
sure that the awards are there for
taxpayers and workers the government has
accepted those and people need to keep
talking to find a way through finally
I'm sure you're aware that ambulance
waiting times are higher than they've
been since records began one in seven of
a Rivals Hospital in an ambulance have
been stuck outside for at least an hour
is your government failing patients
look I want to see ambulance waiting
times come down and that's why in spite
of the difficult decisions we've had to
make we've put more money into the NHS
to help address the waiting times that
people are experiencing one of the ways
we're going to do that is by moving
people out of hospitals back to their
homes back into the communities and
that's why we've invested in Social care
because that money will help provide
more capacity and if we can free up
those beds that will stop some of the
delays that we're seeing and I'm
actually going to sit down with the NHS
relatively soon to make sure that the
plans that we are putting in place are
going to have a real impact as soon as
possible and it's not just older people
prime minister but pediatric beds that
are full doctors not able to treat sick
kids does that make you worried ashamed
concerned well I I care deeply about the
NHS I grew up in an NHS family and
that's why in spite of the difficult
decisions that we've had to make
elsewhere I prioritize the NHS with
extra funding most recently in the
Autumn statement now what I want to make
sure is that extra funding that we're
putting in is actually going to make a
difference on the ground improve the
quality of care people get make sure
that they get that care as quickly as
possible we've put the money in now we
need to see the results and that's what
I'm going to focus on delivering